[Music]
so I've been dating a guy almost six
years he has not let me be a part of his
children's lives he would not let me be
around them we live separately and he's
letting me move in the day after they
graduate saying that if his children
want to be a part of my life they can
make that decision as adult this whole
thing sounds
[Music]
weird what is going on this is John with
the Dr John deloney
show what some meaning my 13-year-old
son and my mom would call the greatest
mental health podcast ever talk about
marriage relationships dude James Childs
was just in here and he just left he
can't even hang anymore the OG producer
here that got this show here's the deal
he he James built the sidewalk there he
is sticking his head back in he he he
put the tires on the car and then he put
the car on the road and then he's like
you know what I quit I'm out I'm going
to a a cooler more established car yeah
he's like I don't like this piece of
Chunk anymore and it was driving the car
was already moving and he's just like H
Kelly you
drive and now we're worldwide Jimmy
Childs just kidding hey it's great to
see you man I miss you my heart feels
good Kelly is way meaner than
you way way but hey uh that sorry you
probably Ed all that out hey it's good
to see everybody and um if you're
listening to me you're like I can't even
see you well I can't see you either but
I'm glad that you are here with us in
the new year um I want to take a second
and tell you this so um my wife's
favorite person on planet Earth as she
likes to tell people is January
John that one month right after New
Year's when I come back guns a blazing
I've changed my diet my workout I'm so
conf kind and helpful and loving and I I
focus on sleep who wants to watch a TV
show what a waste of time let's extract
every second of life march John's not
too great he's not too great um but I
was really slow on the uptake this year
and um you're listening to this at the
end of January most of y'all
statistically have quit all of your um
all of your
uh resolutions you're just not doing it
yeah resolutions and goals I'm getting
there it's a little bit slow today but
today I mean often it's
cool but I'm recording this just after
the new year
started I went
bananas so I'm just saying that to say
this my body is in a state of utter
Revolt
like we're on like day five with no
sugar we're on day five of not just one
not just two but like three workouts a
day like I just went over too far I just
want to see how hard I could push it and
my body's like whoa whoa whoa we had a
deal and you have violated the agreement
John so dude we are in we are in war
with within ourselves so she's not
digging this January John so much well
this January John's just kind of
going yeah and I've never met the
January John that you speak of no you
haven't no no it'd be nice I know it
would be oh well but he always comes
into work and get he gets sad Kelly
dreams it gets joy joy vacuuming domcom
Kelly so
but just wait everybody he's gonna he's
going to be here but U hey I hope youall
doing well hope youall hanging in there
let's go out to Tallahassee Florida and
talk to Mary Mary why what's up Mary oh
not much not
much are you doing all
right yeah I'm I'm doing okay I reckon
very cool so what's
up uh so I've been dating a guy almost
six years and um since his children were
12 and he had has not let me be a part
of his children's lives he will not let
me be around them and we live separately
and he's letting me move in the day
after they graduate saying that if his
children want to be a part of my life
they can make that decision as adults um
and I'm just want to know is that normal
in some people's lives where they don't
want other mother figures to come into
their children's lives and and you know
be influence in any
way uh this whole thing sounds
weird yeah it's it's caused quite a
quite a big issue in our relationship
because when he has his children I can't
see him so they're they're all is he
this sounds like he's got something else
going on no no there's photos of us up
around his home they know about us I
have photos of us together on Facebook
um but when they go to family get
togethers I can't go if his children are
there why have you ever met them I had
to meet them um at a funeral because
someone in his family close passed away
and um of course he didn't want me to go
CU his kids were going to go and I said
I will drive my own car but I'm going
because your family's been part of my
life now for almost six years and they
wanted me to go and they I was invited
by his family and they said we don't
care what he says you are welcome yeah I
would I don't mean to be ugly or
anything but I'd run from this dude as
fast as I can here's why here's why
here's why um he is not living an
integrated
life meaning he is trying to live a life
where he gets to control all the
different segments of his life and by
the way he's done a pretty good job
because you've put up with this crap for
six
years yeah the only way a relationship a
romantic relationship long-term works is
if everybody's all
in now I absolutely believe in slow
playing new
relationships when there's kids from a
previous marriage totally believe in
that good good for him 6 years is
insane it's crazy yes because my
children are around him my and our kids
are the same age that that doesn't mean
anything I don't no but he comes to my
house and eats with my family what's his
reasoning because that's
normal his only reasoning is is that he
the kids can decide when they're grown
but that he will not be and I I'm like
hey you know we're getting close to time
me moving in can I at least come over
some and kind of get to know them
because it's going to be awkward me just
move in and these kids don't know me and
I don't know them and they're going to
still be coming to visit you because
they're still your children why haven't
you married him after more than half a
decade we haven't lived together
so that's the craziest thing I've ever
heard I didn't live with my wife before
we got married most of the people I know
yeah we don't live together because of
the children's situation we live three
miles from each other and it's it has
caused me a lot heartache why do you why
have you put up with this for six years
because here's my promise to you my
promise to you he's hiding other things
from you too period end of story yeah
and there's other parts of his life that
you do not have access to because he
says no and you just take it
why I don't know I guess cuz I'm getting
older and kind of feel like you're just
not worth it you're just going to cash
in on some of like all of a relation I
mean that just breaks my heart for you
yeah it it hurts just because I've I've
stayed where I'm at as a single mom
paying my own bills and I haven't moved
on with my life because I've been
sitting here waiting on him all these
years I'm G tell you right now it's not
going to happen and by the way if it
does you're a half a decade after
thought yeah you know what I mean yeah
it's it's trust me it's caused many and
many and many arguments yeah but
argument four years he wouldn't even
answer the phone with me with the kids
around yeah that's
that why did he get
divorced his ex was having an affair
while he was on government Duty
okay yeah I mean do what you're going to
do um I I don't really know let me do
this what's your question how can I
help I was just want to know if that was
something that was I've never heard of
it happen I've sat with a lot of people
over the years I've never heard of this
I've never heard of six years I won't
answer the phone when you call if I
happen to be with my kids I don't want
you around you're not allowed to talk to
them or meet them because here's the
thing they do have a choice to make when
they're adults 100% yeah they don't have
a choice when they're kids why cuz
they're kids right
and it's the parents job to integrate
themselves right uh Carl Rogers one of
the great uh Godfathers of therapy of
counseling calls it congruence Am I who
I am
everywhere am I the same person here as
I am over here and some of us have a
work face and we have a relationship
face and we have a a church face and we
have uh going to the store face right
and sometimes you see somebody you're
like dude I don't even know that guy
that is not who I or you see somebody at
work and you see them out at you know at
a restaurant and they're just like on
top of the table with two Margarita
pitches and you're like what um that's a
person that's exhausted because they
have to be multiple people throughout
their life yeah and it's very hard to
have a relationship with somebody who
does not is not aiming towards
congruence yeah it's it's been difficult
and I guess the reason I haven't given
up is because I've already put so much
time in in in business we call that
don't cost
fallacy I've already put $2 million in
this oh your business is failing well I
know but I've already put 2 million so I
got to put another million in I know but
it's failing it's not working I got to
put another million in right it's just
some cost fallacy Bankers love you he
just says things he says things are
going to be different you know I'm going
to move in and things are going to be
better and this won't be an issue
anymore but I'm like but what about the
other six years that I sat a whole loan
on Christmas because my kids were at
their dad's or I sat alone on
Thanksgiving because you I couldn't be
with you and your family cuz you had
your children it's been really
crappy yeah I mean I don't have an
answer for you other than that's gonna
have that's going to have to be
something you all address
together yeah and for him he's not on
the phone so I can't talk to him but for
him if he says I told you at the outset
you can never meet my children until
they're adults period yep end of story
that's what he said yep that's what he
said he said I told you on the the first
date then here's the deal all of this is
on you you chose to sit at home on
Christmas I'm not even going to blame
him yeah and that's what he said he said
I told you the first date you stayed and
of course my thinking was oh when he
finds out what kind of a good woman I am
that I won't do him like he's been done
he'll he'll change and I realiz that
you're the first woman in history that
thought they could change a man did you
know I know the first one no I here's
the thing I if he was my buddy I would
have said don't I don't think that's
wise but I don't get a vote he didn't
call me and ask me so in that regard ask
anybody he can do whatever he wants
you're the one that chose to stay yeah
his family thinks he's crazy well it
doesn't matter what they think it
matters what you
accept you've outsourced I'm still here
okay then here's what I'm gonna ask you
to do make make do make peace with it
move on because you moving into him in
into his
house and not marrying him and basically
becoming another one of his children by
the way because he's going to continue
to tell you what to do but you're going
to move into his house if you bring with
you these choices that you made to be
alone at Christmas and at Thanksgiving
and you bring with you your anger at him
for not letting you meet his kids for
six years you're choosing to poison this
part of your
life right he sounds like he was pretty
damn up front with you he was he was and
you chose to stay so I'm gonna ask you
to
either uh put your anger on the table
and say no more or to make peace with it
yeah say I chose this I'm gonna move on
I have done that I did say when you know
I move in I'm not going to be I'm not a
living girlfriend I'm wife material and
if you don't want to you know no you're
GNA be you're gonna be playing house
you'll be playing
house he he has a
year yeah Mary I when do you move
in
May you move in this may so he has until
May of
yes I will give you 10 products from the
ramsy solution store if you're married
by May of 26 of
25 okay I call I'll be sure I call you
back oh dude you sent an email in you
sent us a a copy of your wedding phot I
will I will send you a link you can buy
get whatever you want out of here here's
why yeah why in the world would he marry
you I know right like he's already got
the whole Farm the cows the chickens the
Ducks I don't think you're a cow or a
chicken or a duck but I think you're a
pretty awesome lady but he has no why
why in the world would he complicate his
life like that yeah for six years you
you just put up with anything he says
however he says it I know I know
I kind I don't really have I mean I have
a lot I could say but it's that right it
sounds it sounds not great right yeah
yeah so here's the deal um now if he was
my friend and he called me I would have
told him to do something different he
didn't cool he did he said was was going
to say and to his credit he called it on
day one this is the way this is going to
be and so you made some challenging
decisions that left you is ated and
alone and you thought you could change
him and you thought once Here's the the
the the biggest CH the biggest um miss
that you had here was you thought this
was about
you and somebody along the lines in your
life told you that
you weren't worth very
much yeah I grew up in foster care okay
and you were going to prove it to
him yeah and what you have to realize
here is that you were left in F foster
care not because of anything you
did yeah it was what was going on in
your parents
life yeah I just thought that it was me
like am I not a good enough parent to my
own children that you don't want your
children around me it was never about
you it was about
him and that's both should be both
freeing and kind of a
bummer because if you're going to marry
somebody they're telling you my life is
now all about you and you're telling
them that their life is all about you
that's what we're doing when we get
married well he say he's going
to and hey you know what he's been a man
of his word so far for the last half
decade so that's true I mean he may he
may he may invite you in on on May 1 and
y'all are married June 10th and I'm out
10 products here at at the store maybe
that's the case
um this is just a it's a bigger
conversation here's the conversation a
you can't change people B people make
choices because they want to make
choices period
period and
finally man if somebody's choosing to
hide parts of their life from you it's
very hard to have a romantic
relationship that has any
value other than this than you're
underwater and you're both just taking
gulps of air out of one um scuba diving
tank
when somebody in a marriage is or or in
a long relationship y'all been playing
married for a long time when somebody
when you in a relationship and
somebody's hiding things whether it's an
addiction whether it's pornography
whether it's an affair whether it's you
can't see my kids you I won't even call
you on Christmas Day because I'm with
them so we've been together four years I
don't care you do not exist on this day
I'll call you
later um all you're doing is just
trading gulps of
air you're not both sitting on the beach
you're both underwater barely
surviving here's my recommendation Mary
as you head into this new season by the
way I don't think you should move in I
think you should get married
first and uh that's just me um you don't
need a practice run you'all been
together six years you kind of know what
you got sounds like he's a man of his
word that concrete uh I would make a a
very firm list here's my boundaries
here's what I will accept no longer
except period end of story and then you
got to come up with your or what
statement if this doesn't change then
what then I'm out then I'm just going to
take it that's fine whatever your or
what statement is um you need to come up
with it and be firm with it before you
move in otherwise you're just going to
subject yourself to this
indefinitely to answer your original
question nope never heard of this before
this one's a new one even for
me love this show we'll be right
back this episode is sponsored by better
help hey it's delone last year I came to
an inflection point I was exercising
regularly I was disciplined in my diet I
was getting regular blood work done and
I was working hard on my marriage I was
doing all the right things but I had not
dealt with old traumas and old stories
that were negatively impacting my
marriage my relationship with my kids my
work and me I'm the expert I teach
others what to do but I was slowly piece
by piece falling apart so I swallowed my
pride and with the encouragement of my
family and friends I reached out to a
therapist and started seeking true deep
healing a year later I'm a radically
different man all for the better and I
know finding a therapist in your local
community can be almost impossible or if
you do find one it's so expensive you
can't afford to go even if you wanted to
and that's why I love the work
betterhelp is doing in the world
betterhelp is online therapy with real
license therapist who are available on
your schedule when you contact better
help you will fill out a short
questionnaire and they will match you
with the licensed therapist plus you can
switch therapist at any time for no
extra charge you've been working so so
hard and now it's time to get to the
root of your pain for permanent
extraordinary life change visit
betterhelp.com delonay to get 10% off
your first month that's betterhelp
hp.com all right we are back let's go to
Dallas Texas and talk to the great and
wonderful Dean Hey Brother Dean what's
up not much Dr John how are you doing
today I'm all right brother what's up
man how can it
help well let's see the problem
statement would be this I don't have
anybody to talk
to and talk to about that what that
really means is talk as in personal
stuff deep things uh venting on somebody
or something like that
so kind of puts me in a situation of
being pretty well isolated yeah do you
end up spending a lot of time online
trying to find common bonds
there no actually I don't good for you
man good for you um yeah I don't think
there's going to be a whole lot of
common Bond
there um so have you always been kind of
a Lone Ranger is this new that you found
yourself did you recently move like tell
me tell me the story how you came to
realize dude I got nobody well I left
home about 50 years ago uh all over the
world working living I live about half
my adult life's been outside the country
uh I think I've had like 37 38 different
addresses in my life so yeah move around
you know how it is when you go into a uh
subdivision lived there five six years
you see all the neighbors but you don't
know any of their names yeah yeah
um how old are you man 66 66 so why now
why have you thought man I need some
people well a little light bulb went off
one
day and uh uh my wife and I were having
a bit of a um a
disagreement and I got to thinking about
it I said well she's got her ladies
group and they all go C up and do their
thing and whatnot and I don't have
anybody to go talk to I think I need to
do something about that good for you man
D you're like a uh
modernday uh
hero I'm not I'm not kidding here's why
most 66 yearold men who have a
disagreement with their wife and their
wife goes off to their friends to have
somebody they can just process it with
um they just sit in their
chair and they watch TV or or they get
on some crazy conspiratorial website and
go down a rabbit hole or they go into
the garage and Tinker with something
which is's nothing wrong with tinkering
but man recognizing dude I need somebody
to talk to so here's the
thing I've talked about this almost Ed
nauseum I'm going to send you um two of
my books okay for free I'm just going to
hook you up with them if you'll read
them and there's some pretty extensive
stuff in both of them about both the
epidemic of loneliness it's just killing
us man from the inside out and some very
practical steps on what to do but I
usually distill it down into a couple of
things and I'll just ask you point blank
how weird are you willing to
get to find
weird
um I have a neighbor I live out in the
woods and out in what they call in these
parts out in the holler I thought it was
like a road in a valley but it's not
it's a holler and she literally
got on a horse and went door Todo cuz
these places are all like multiple acres
and she held a big uh cookout and told
everybody to bring a meal and we met by
the side of the road on a
creek and it was the funnest most
hilarious somebody brought a guitar
somebody brought their kids my kids are
running around all over the place um it
was a group of randos from multi- multi-
multi-millionaire attorneys to people
who' lived down in the holler for years
that had there were the retired Farmers
that had basically nothing I mean it was
amazing but it took one person going
door to door to door to door to do that
I've also heard of I'm thinking back
back to um during covid when I had a
neighbor come up at down and said hey
I'm doing a barbecue we're all going to
sit outside in lawn chairs and the first
one was kind of sparsely attended he had
meat out there on some tables had some
chairs out there there was four or five
of us down there the next one had like
70 people out there cool and so I don't
know if it's you saying want to hang out
and have coffee and put a sign in your
yard and you sit out in the front yard
and have a card table out there and
drink coffee until somebody comes and
you can read a book um or you go to a
local Starbucks and buy somebody coffee
or you go to your local church and you
say hey I want to have a group of guys
that just get together and drink coffee
on Tuesday Mornings who's in and you're
going to have to know that it's just
going to take time over and over and
over of showing up and showing up and
showing up finally somebody's going to
go hey man my wife's not all
right see what I'm saying yeah yeah but
I don't know a way of you finding
friends without a you going first and B
you being willing to um endure rejection
and just be weird and I say it's weird
it's not weird but in this modern world
to say hello to a stranger is is
somewhat weird that's pretty weird yeah
yeah or you instantly think what do you
want trying to sell me something
nope I bet you know what I bet if you
put a sign in your front yard that just
said lonely 66 year-old I've got great
coffee would love for you to hang out
and you put a car table in your driveway
I guarantee you I'd pull over and stop
and hang out with you I would call Kelly
and tell her I'm missing the show today
because I'm hanging out with my new
buddy
Dean I mean I here's the thing there's
any number of opportunities here I think
the big thing is you got to take action
on it it's not just going to it's not
going to heal itself yeah
are you connected with the local church
there um we go I don't spend a lot of
time there but
uh or a local Civic group or do you even
have a counselor that you can talk to
for a little while while you kind of
building this thing up that I don't have
okay and uh you know so that was one of
the things that I looked at is you know
maybe maybe go down that route and find
somebody to talk to you know but you
know five years a once a week is pretty
price I don't think insurance is going
to cover that n and I don't think I mean
from what you're telling me right here I
don't think you need five years in once
a week what a good counselor is going to
do is they're going to practice with you
the skill and art of conversation and
listening and being present with
somebody and those things are necessary
for someone to come tell you some deep
things or to listen when you tell them
deep things that you're experiencing
yeah right so I don't think you're going
to get stuck in a five-year Loop by the
way you can always just walk away you
don't have to go but on the way to the
office today I had a someone who's a a
former colleague of mine who's in their
late 50s maybe early 60s who reached out
and I gave them the name of two
therapist I don't think that's weird at
all cool fact I just did that today to
somebody I care about so all that to say
um I think it's just going to take some
action and by the way you probably going
to need to learn some skills you've
moved a lot huh oh I've moved a lot yeah
you're great acquaintance but probably
being a ride or die friend at 2: a. is
Pretty Tough oh yeah absolutely okay
dude I'm proud of you man you give me
hope well thanks you give me hope man
but yeah um hang on the line here I'm
gonna hook you up with um both own your
past change your future and building a
non-anxious life and there's some pretty
clear directives on friendship and
building friends and the how we got to
where we got and what we do to walk out
of it but um at the end of the the day
it's my friend Michael Easter he's like
dude I'm going to work out on on I'm
going to do my burn the ships workout
once a week if you're in Vegas you're
welcome to come um I'm trying to get
better about inviting people out with me
hey I'm going rucket if you want to come
let's do it I'd love for love to have
you and you my
friend whether it's front porch coffee
with Dean whether it's a sign in a local
Starbucks whether it is hey I'm gonna
get a bunch of fajitas I'm going to
grill them out and I'm going to try to
do a neighborhood potluck and the first
one is going to be a bust let me tell
you it's not going to be great the
second one though might be awesome might
be great man meet your neighbors say
hello if you put a flyer I'm just going
to challenge you if you put a flyer on
the 10 houses to your right 10 houses to
your left across the street same 10 and
10 that's 40 houses and you said I'm
Grill and fajitas I'd love everybody to
come over for a potluck I'll have the
tables and you line up the tables on
your driveway invite everybody tell tell
everybody bring a dish and bring a lawn
chair bring your drinks or whatever man
you you're going to meet some neighbors
that could be fantastic what a cool cool
thing to do and everybody
listening we're entering into an
election year that's just what we
freaking need good
God my goodness I would
rather the list of things I would rather
do than enter into another election
season not pretty and probably not good
for radio um or for
podcast we need each other man we're
going to need a big time this year call
your neighbors set something up I'm
going to commit to doing it hope you
will too we'll be right
back I'm always getting asked if there
are any new products that I've run
across that are changing the game for
anxiety worry focus and sleep and if
you've listened to this show I'm always
telling you that technology won't save
us because we don't need bioh hacks we
need to transform our nervous systems
through movement mindfulness nature and
so forth and while I still believe in
critically important Lifestyle Changes I
have discovered a new wearable that is
literally changing my life and my
family's life I'm wearing it around my
ankle right now and if I didn't know
that it was the result of brilliant
neuroscientists and Technology experts
working together I would think this
device came straight out of Hogwarts
It's Magic I'm talking about Apollo or
also known as the Apollo wearable you
can wear it on your wrist like I said
I'm wearing mine on my ankle you can
just clip it to your shirt and it
actively improves your health by
transforming and strengthening your
nervous system it doesn't just measure
your health and fitness it changes you
for the better Apollo delivers gentle
pulse vibrations that feel like your
body is experiencing the Rhythm and
beats of different songs these higher
vibrations help improve energy and focus
while lowering vibrations reduce stress
and help you relax since day one I've
experienced less stress more energy
relaxation and focus and get this my rim
sleep improved more than 90% from one
night to the next
I know since wearing Apollo I'm a better
husband a better dad and I can show up
better for all of you and my kids are
getting in on the Apollo to you cannot
improve your marriage your relationship
to your kids or how you show up in your
community if you're not sleeping if
you're riddled with anxiety and if
you're not able to focus along with
making changes about how you choose a
non-anxious life the Apollo wearable is
a game changer that can accelerate your
healing Journey go to apollon neo.com
delone or go to apollon neo.com and use
promo code delone a checkout for 15% off
your purchase it's changing my life and
it can change
yours all right we're back and in
celebration of the New Year the most
common question we've received on the
show for the last few months
is some semblance of this question
John's always talking about this
strategic plan he does with his wife
every year this meeting they have or
this retreat they have what do they talk
talk about how do they do it like what
are the ins and outs of this thing and
then how do you keep it going throughout
the year right so I want to break down
for you what me and my wife have done
why we do it where it's come from and
more importantly like here's the things
we talk about and here's the way we keep
this thing going throughout the year so
um it started about I don't know 15
years ago I was working at a university
maybe a little bit less than that there
was a the dean of the College of
Business his name was Dr Rick Lidle a
great guy but he came to talked to to my
team and one of the things he said that
he did with his family was they did a
strategic plan every year and I was like
well of course you're the dean of a
business college that makes sense sounds
lame but cool and then he said this he
said why in the world would I spend all
this time and preparation and money and
Gatherings and all this energy building
a strategic plan for a
business something that is going to go
away
someday and not put that level of time
energy and intentionality into my family
and the light bulb went off I was like
oh my gosh I'm just expecting my family
to happen I'm expecting my marriage to
happen I'm expecting my money just to
figure itself out I'm just expecting to
I don't know have a Tahoe and three
houses and a whatever and a partridge in
a parat Tre I just expected this crap to
happen and I expect my marriage to be
awesome and the sex to always be amazing
and the kids to raise themselves I just
I mean when he said that I was like yeah
we got to be intentional about this and
then I did nothing I did nothing for a
while I had a couple of ideas maybe we
went to a breakfast on New Year's you
know here and there and then we got to a
place my wife and I where we had to
decide are we going to stay married we
reached a point where sitting across a
table a grown-up table and saying we're
going to be adults are we going to stay
married because if we're going to stay
married we can't keep doing this this
has to change this has to change this
has to change and that started a very I
remembered that conversation with Dr
Lidle and so that started a very
intentional strategic plan so here's
what it looks like and the form people
get caught up in the form the same way
they get caught up in Daily morning
routines they get caught up in what's
the exact supplement that's less
important sometimes um over the last
five to seven years my wife and I have I
think it's more about five to six years
is when we've been doing this really
religiously um once we went out of town
and just spent a weekend together once
we did a progressivist my favorite one
so far was we got a babysitter maybe my
parents were in town but we did an
entire day we started somewhere for
coffee we then went to breakfast we then
went somewhere and went for a walk and
we went to lunch somewhere and then we
spent all afternoon in another coffee
shop and then we had a nice dinner to
kind of wrap up the evening but and then
this year we had to do it on three
separate days some years it's been
awesome just being honest this years it
was not great I wasn't feeling great I
was not super excited about the new year
I came with this picture in my head she
came with that picture in her head and
it was like G so we had to have a fourth
meeting right but here's how we but how
you do it whether you have to break it
up one hour increments or I'm going to
do it a couple of Saturdays or I'm going
to do it we're going to go on a retreat
once a year um or twice a year here's
the important thing a carve out some
time very intentional time half a day I
think you can't do it a minimum and and
you got to have four hours hours to do
this probably more that means somebody's
got to get child care somebody's got to
ask their mom and dad to come up and
visit or maybe you're on the holidays
and you're staying at your in-law's
house we did that one year where we went
away and we left the kids while we were
on vacation we went away and did it set
aside some intentional time decide on a
budget for the
day we're gonna we're going to spend 500
bucks today we're going to spend $100
today we don't have any money at all so
we're going to just do coffee and water
and then we're going to eat at
McDonald's to celebrate I don't care
what it is um pick the time in the place
and then here's this is important you
got to do your homework separately and
if you're not willing to do separate
homework you're not willing to have this
meeting and you probably have bigger
issues in your marriage and homework
does not mean you have to do a whole
year okay here's what the homework is
here's some questions and this is from a
list that my wife and I actually use
ourselves how do you feel about last
year what are some things from last year
you're really proud of what are some
challenges you faced
and here's what you find you're going to
find that that um y'all didn't know the
other person was facing this challenge
or maybe you absolutely did know but
you're going to find some things out um
what are you most looking forward to
next year who are you becoming what are
four or five ways I could love you
better each one of these can be answered
in five minutes most of the time it goes
on it talks and then it opens up this
can of worms and whatever whatever
reflect on the past year what do we need
to grieve this one was really important
for us this year we had some Big Dreams
and the dreams didn't die they just
changed and I realized I'm still holding
on to this thing but everything's
different now what do we need to
grieve what Milestones do we need to
celebrate stop and celebrate how did we
handle challenges as a team is there
anything we like to change next year and
then we're going to get into the hard
conversations we're going to talk about
sex and intimacy we're going to talk
about our health we're talk about
parenting how are you feeling have you
got a blood test I've gained 30 lbs you
look like you don't feel good I feel
separate from you whatever that happens
to be parenting how are our kids doing
and how are we both working together to
support our kids money is a big one
money's a big one I'm going to link to
this um in the show notes a lot of this
can be funneled through money um every
dollar is the best budgeting app on
planet Earth and it forces couples to
sit at a table and decide what is
important to us and how do we want to
spend our money um I'm going to put a
link to is I think it's free month or
three months or something like that of
the premium version of it um but I'll
put a link to in the show notes it's
awesome it's the one I use with my
family uh with my wife um schedule and
commitments my wife and I go through a
calendar then we talk about work I don't
have a book coming out this year but I
did last year so last year we a lot of
our conversation was what's life going
to be like when you're on touring the
country this year it's going to be a
little bit different the conversations
but we put those things on the calendar
and we put big plans for trips or not
trips or holidays or whatever that thing
is then we get very granular and decide
action
items who's going to actually hit the
button to to pay this
bill who is going to call for the sitter
we okay we're gonna have date night
every two weeks who's going to call the
sitter because one of you is just going
to expect the other one to do it let's
just sit down and go through all of
those
things and then what my wife and I do
every every week as we get together um
we used to do it on Sunday nights this
year we're going to start doing it more
on Saturday mornings and I give my kids
screen time once a week because I'm in
Neanderthal and they'll Sprint upstairs
and play video game or watch cartoons
whatever my wife when I I'll spend
several hours working through the week
and then we go for a really really long
long long walk a long Rock um and we
make that a plan we do that every
Saturday just kind of becomes the way
things are sometimes the Saturday
conversations aren't pretty they're more
of us bickering and fighting and I can't
believe this and I don't feel like this
and whatever sometimes they're so
energetic and awesome it's just the EB
and flow it's a roller coaster right I'm
not getting off so it's just part of the
ride and then here's the important
thing over the years you'll tailor this
to yourself I'm actually thinking about
coming up with a leatherbound journal
for couples that you would take on your
retreat at the beginning of the year and
then you would fill it in every week for
your weekly meeting if you're interested
in that shoot me a DM on Instagram or
email the show um john.com ask ask um
let me know if you're into that because
it would be a I want it to be something
that both that a dude's not going to
feel weird carrying around but that
would be good for everybody and here's
my dream my dream is you would have 10
of these or 15 of these and or 25 of
these journals and your kids will get to
watch The Arc of their parents what they
worked through what they thought through
what their budget was 25 years ago
versus what what it is now how you
handled X or Y or Z or whatever um but
I'd love to have a really nice strong um
leatherbound like here's our strategic
plan this is going to get us through the
year and here's the final thing no that
life will change somebody will get
cancer some kids going to get sick some
kids gonna have to leave school
something's someone's going to have to
fly to home to Texas because Something's
Happened to Dad whatever the thing is
hold it
Loosely plan really well and then hold
it Loosely because once the once the
bullets start flying then things kind of
go out the window that's the point of
the plan point a of the plan oh I'll
just say what Patrick lenon
says the importance of his the plan part
of the Strategic plan it's a byproduct
it's a byproduct of actually getting
together and talking and listening and
going back and forth and getting on the
same page the plan is cool but the
plan's going to change
what's not going to change is that you
and your partner get
together and say Come What May I'm going
to be right
here and you can count on me and I'm
going to count on you and we have some
agreement about where we're headed and
if life throws us a curveball we're
going to sit down and talk about it and
then we're going to go from there but
that's what we do every year um we do
have a summer we get together for half a
day just kind of check in see how things
are going how are you doing you still
like me that kind of stuff um but the
beginning of the year that strategic
planning season is really really
important and what's now fun is looking
back five years ago and saying I want to
have this much money I want to have a
house I want our kids to be this healthy
and safe and to look and see we've
accomplished a lot of that stuff it's
pretty awesome to watch The Journey so
use that for how you will I'm going to
put a link to this PDF that my wife and
I use in the show notes here and you can
check it out um and we'll be right
back hey I've got some great news for
you you get to choose whatever you do
good or bad moving forward the choice is
yours and when you're intentional about
making good choices over time they
become Healthy Habits Like choosing to
slow down and make time for a daily
practice of prayer and meditation one
thing that helps me every single day is
hallow hallow is the number one Prayer
app in the world on planet Earth and
they're giving you three free months to
get started people always say you got to
meditate you got to pray you got to have
a spiritual life and for many of us we
don't even know what that means we don't
even know where to start that's where
hallow steps in three free months to
prioritize your mental health your
spiritual health and be intentional
about finding peace through calming
music the LOI station that I love guided
prayers meditations and more and hallow
isn't just Catholic you can tailor the
content towards your faith tradition
from scripture readings and prayers to
journaling Hall makes it easy to
practice mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life to figure out
what you even believe in the first place
and choose peace and remember Hall is
giving you 90 days free imagine the
peaceful habits you can establish in 90
days go to hall.com dealone toay and
follow the simple prompts to start your
free 90-day trial that's hall.com
delone all right as we wrap up today's
show we have Kelly's favorite
installment am I the problem go for it
all right this is from Lisa and she says
my boyfriend wants to put cameras in
this in his house he has them on the
outside at entry points exit points but
now he wants them inside for quote
unquote security I don't stay there very
often but it still feels like an
intrusion no one wants to be witnessed
picking and grinning am I the jerk for
opposing to spend time when there's
cameras
rolling
I just want to like read between the
lines here sounds like he wants to video
them having sex and she doesn't want
that um I mean I know some people that
have cameras in their houses um she's
under the impression she doesn't want to
be yeah I don't think I would
want that I mean that would be weird to
be like you know I'm just walking around
the house going to get something to
drink and you know all your tattoos are
showing yeah and I mean but it I don't I
would want to know what his reasonings
are because have there been people
breaking the house can you just get
security systems like we have security
systems on all of our windows and
everything like that you know and in the
house
um here here's what to answer the
question you're not weird for anything
that makes you feel unsafe right and
when I say weird I'm saying your body's
trying to get your get your attention
and tell you something that's not that's
not abnormal if that thing interferes
with your life to a degree where you
can't function so like clowns right I'm
scared of clowns and then there's people
who cannot go into a room with a doll
like I their body seizes up they'll
throw up they get like they start
sweating from the inside out all right
well let's go to the counsel let's work
through that the procedure for working
through that is relatively
straightforward the only good clown is a
dead clown I just want that out there
exactly it wouldn't be so weird if you
didn't have a big tattoo of Bozo on your
neck or trust me I do not I hate
clowns it's on her it's on her lower
back that was her her clown stamp so
good but hey whatever you feel is like
hey I'm just not comfortable with this
own
that as for inside the house
cameras I I get it I I if I went to
somebody's house and I knew I was being
m monitored I would feel uncomfortable
the whole time I was there yeah you'd
feel self-conscious now there are like
when when um when we were having to live
in the rental after the house flooded
there was no reason for anyone to be
upstairs um because and that's where we
had put most of our stuff so we had a
camera set up at the like at the top of
the stairs that's the security issue
exactly it's a security issue that's not
just hey girlfriend yeah at one point in
time we had to have a camera in our
daughter's room um because there was
some some she was doing some things that
potentially could harm her safety issues
that's right right but
I mean we don't just have cameras in the
house I would just question the motives
behind that yeah not not that he's doing
anything wrong but
just what's going on let me say this go
with your gut if I went over to Kelly's
house whose whose husband Kelly's
husband works in police security and he
was telling me about his camera systems
inside the house I wouldn't even think
twice of that because that's what he
does that's who he is right if I on over
to Nate dog's house who's creepy MC
creepster and he's like hey guys I got
cameras all inside I would be like this
is kind of gross this feels this doesn't
feel right you know what I mean it's
like going into somebody's house and
they have carpet on the walls it just
it's like uh things are a little bit
Shady so I think you kind of know and so
if you're a woman writing the writing in
or you're listening to this go with your
gut on this something is telling you I
don't like this and so no I don't think
you're weird I don't think you're weird
do you no I don't think she's the
problem at all and I'm not saying he's
the problem either yeah they just if
it's not something she's not comfortable
with and he's adamant about it that's
just where it is a Felicia yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yeah or maybe you can't be picking and
grining in the main room maybe that's
the issue all right hey thanks for
hanging out with us make good
choices I mean go all in on your
resolutions don't get off the wagon if
you've already gotten off the wagon get
back on don't do it all at once cuz your
body will Revolt love you guys bye
[Music]
w